bonjour bonjour à tous et à toutes
je m'appelle thomas j'ai 27 ans et je
fais de la musique quand j'étais tout
bébé
j'adorais aller sous le piano et pendant
ce temps là mon père en général à ce
qu'ils faisaient ce qu'ils jouent et je
veux des morceaux de musique classique
et notamment le début de la sonate
appassionata de beethoven qui est très
très impressionnant et il me racontait
une histoire par dessus il disait tu
vois ça c'est un petit fin il s'est
perdu dans la forêt et puis là il ya un
grand méchant loup qui le voit et qui
commence à poursuivre et puis finalement
bon je fais là toute l'histoire mais à
la fin il était sauvé par son père le
grand cerf évidemment et moi ça me
fascinait et j'ai appelé ça le gros
beethoven je disais tu peux jouer le
groupe étoffe et quand j'ai commencé le
piano j'ai demandé à tous mes premiers
professeurs de piano de m'enseigner
cette partition évidemment c'était
beaucoup trop difficile pour un débutant
mais c'est pas grave parce que j'avais
compris qu'on pouvait raconter des
histoires avec de la musique et ça
c'était incroyable pour moi
ce qui fait que très tôt j'ai eu envie
d'en faire moi aussi donc j'écrivais des
petits morceaux des petites chansons et
puis le sujet c'était mon chien mon chat
la première fois que j'ai fait de la
planche à voile ou les premières filles
qui nous fait tourner la tête comme ça
est ce que j'aime par dessus tout
c'était avoir l'occasion de créer des
univers et faire intervenir des
personnages dedans et pour sahin
instruments comme le piano c'est parfait
parce que c'est un instrument qui peut
être à la fois orchestre et chanteur
alors après bon j'ai quitté l'école à 15
ans je suis entré au conservatoire de
paris mais ils m'ont viré très peu de
temps après et heureusement que mes
parents avaient pas accorder pas trop
d'importance aux diplômes parce que moi
c'était le cadre qui m'embêtait en
général alors mon meilleur souvenir
d'adolescence c'était deux années
pendant lesquelles j'étais hors de tout
système scolaire
j'habitais à la campagne j'étais
complètement libre et j'avais aucun
cadre prédéfini
c'était moi qui définissent et
non-cadres jour après jour alors
certains matins je me lever à 6h et puis
je m'enfermais dans le studio devant le
piano toute la journée et je travaille
et je travaille et je comptais pas les
heures et puis à un moment c'était juste
le chien qui arrivent et qui grattait à
la porte avec un ballon dans la gueule
en dix ans
je viens on va faire une pause et puis
d'autres jours c'était le contraire je
me vais plutôt tard et puis je passe le
plus clair de la journée
allongé sur mon lit à lire des romans et
puis de temps en temps il y avait une
mélodie quelques notes qui tournaient
dans ma tête alors je me retournais
j'écrivais sur le mur ou sur le bord de
la table
bon voilà et puis c'était c'était très
naturel est quasiment toutes ces idées
sont devenus des morceaux de musique les
chansons plus tard que j'ai pu exploiter
enfin en un mot j'étais complètement
libre alors j'étais un peu seule aussi
c'est sûr mais j'étais tellement libre
que c'était vraiment grisant et j'ai
jamais été aussi productif et
travailleurs et créatif que pendant ces
deux années sans jamais avoir
l'impression de travailler et très
naturellement j'ai fait de cette passion
la musique le terreau toute ma vie
aujourd'hui là j'ai vraiment la chance
immense de pouvoir vivre de ma passion
et je recherche à chaque instant cette
ses sensations de liberté que j'ai eu
pendant ces quelques années alors être
libre ça veut pas dire ne pas avoir de
règles parce que si on n'a pas de
contrainte
si on n'a pas de cadre on est perdu en
fait quand on est perdu on est coincé
donc on n'est pas libre ce qu'il faut
c'est apprendre à jouer avec les règles
à évoluer librement dans un cadre défini
mais à se donner la possibilité aussi de
briser le cadre à tout moment et d'en
construire un autre dans inventer
d'autres indéfiniment en fait j'ai
compris avec le piano et notamment avec
le jazz parce que c'est ça que je fais
surtout c'est du jazz et c'est de
l'improvisation que être capable
d'imaginer d'autres structures c'est
libérer totalement son présent et son
futur
alors là je parle de piano de musique au
sein d'un morceau mais en fait dans la
vie pour moi c'est exactement pareil
c'est juste une petite cellule qui
représente une plus grande cellule
d'ailleurs ça m'a toujours fasciné qu'on
utilise le mot cellule à la fois pour
parler de la prison et la biologie de la
cellule qui qui est la plus petite unité
autonome de la ville en fête
enfin en tout cas les règles sont une
condition à la liberté il faut juste
bien les choisir ne pas trop les prendre
au sérieux
enfin s'amuser avec par exemple on va
prendre une mélodie classique très
célèbre pour le piano qui a été composée
par robert schuman en 1839 je crois
s'appelle arabesques opus 18 le thème
vous l'avez sûrement déjà entendu
et c'est alors on va changer les règles
parce que là dedans il ya des règles on
va imaginer que schumann donc qui a
écrit ça il en a un peu marre de la
grisaille en allemagne et des problèmes
avec sa femme clara bon c'est pas la
joie
il décide de s'embarquer sur un bateau
pour les caraïbes et il débarque en
guadeloupe alors il arrive le premier
soir il fait la teuf toute la nuit
il boit beaucoup beaucoup de petits
ponts beaucoup et ça se met à tanguer
très fort dans sa tête alors qu'ils
s'attendent qu'est ce qu'on va faire on
va changer le rythme c'était à quatre
temps on va le mettre je sais pas à 50
ans voilà faire ça on va improviser
là-dessus librement on va d'abord
interprété le thème de façon plus livre
on va on va improviser sur les harmonies
du morceau alors les harmonies qu'est ce
que c'est les harmonies d'un morceau de
musique
les harmonies c'est en quelque sorte les
couleurs de la musique les couleurs dans
lesquels on dessine des mélodies par
exemple si je reprends les mêmes on va
dire jaune bleu jaune bleu
pourpre vert rose foncé vers un peu plus
foncée c'est pour moi mais pour vous ça
peut être un peu différent alors
mélodies harmonie rythme on a là les
trois éléments principaux de la musique
de tout type de musique
il y en a d'autres mais en gros ça sont
les principaux donc on va jouer avec ces
trois éléments qui sont trois cadres
trois cadres dans lesquels on peut
évoluer mais 3,4 qu'on peut aussi casser
c'est à dire qu'on peut improviser
d'autres mélodies sur ses harmonies et
ce rythme on peut sortir du cadre des
harmonies fait qu'on veut et on peut
aussi changer le rythme faire des
groupes différents
donc on va faire ça maintenant aller
donner un petit peu de soleil à schumann
elle
ans
ainsi
alors est-ce que c'est du jazz
est-ce que c'est du classique un mariage
entre les deux ça c'est sûr mais même un
mariage avec eux d'autres trucs évident
moi j'aime pas du tout les cases on a
tendance aujourd'hui toujours à mettre
des choses en des 15 alors on met la
musique dans des cases mais aussi les
gens dans des cases
le problème des cases c'est qu'elle
enferme complètement et elle nous pousse
à évoluer dans l'idée qu'on a de ces
cases c'est à dire que le problème c'est
que si je dis à quelqu'un toi ce que tu
fais c'est ça ou ce que tu es
c'est ça tu fais ça tu fais ça tu es
comme si tu es comme ça je le fige dans
une image que j'ai de lui et non
seulement je m'attends à ce qu'ils s'y
conforment mais surtout lui-même souvent
n'imagine pas qu'ils puissent en sortir
et donc ils s'y conforment donc les
cases c'est ces choses dans lesquelles
on arrange les choses et les gens sont
un énorme frein à la liberté et à la
créativité et c'est le même problème
avec les mots d'une manière générale les
mots aussi beau et fin soit ils ont
tendance à figer les choses dans un sens
un sens unique
à moins d'être vraiment un grand poète
est pour moi la musique c'est un moyen
absolument génial de pouvoir exprimer
des choses qui dépassent les mots alors
comment en s'adressant au coeur en fait
tout simplement au coeur humain ce coeur
qui est capable instantanément de capter
et de comprendre des choses immense
puissante complexe contradictoire des
questions parfois sans barrière de
langage et je me suis dit qu'en
s'adressant à quelque chose d'autre que
l'intellect des gens quelque chose qui
est plus primaires en plus instinctif -
moins conscients moins réfléchi on a une
chance et une occasion d'être compris
par eux et de partager avec eux sur un
autre plan un plan peut être plus
profond plus complexe
et quelques mois j'ai eu l'occasion de
faire un atelier pour des enfants juste
avant un concert il ya eu plusieurs
classes d'enfants qui sont venus il
avait entre 5 et 8 ans vraiment petit il
était assis par terre autour du piano
moi j'étais là et puis un moment je leur
jouet des petites improvisations très
courte et après chacune je leur
demandais ce que ça leur évoqué comme
sentiments comme sensation alors à ma
grande surprise il tombait toujours
d'accord il était je n'ai pas 20 ou 30
je jouais un truc et il est la peur jean
genet un autre la joie puis encore un
autre et tristesse c'était vraiment
super mignon mais je me suis arrêté et
je leur ai dit comment ça se fait que
vous tombiez toujours d'accord à
l'unanimité
c'est à dire on se connaît pas on n'a
pas répété
et à chaque fois je vous jure quelque
chose vous ressentez les mêmes choses
tous autant que vous êtes et vous êtes
tous d'accord
pourquoi avez vous regardé j'étais un
peu embêté y réfléchissait puis petite
fille un moment qui a levé la moyenne
elle m'a dit c'est parce qu'on est
humain et voilà on y était pile dedans
c'est à dire que ils étaient une
trentaine il y avait des blancs des
noirs des beurs des asiatiques des juifs
des musulmans des chrétiens des athées
des riches des pauvres des garçons des
filles copains pas copains mais peu
importe on était tous en train de
partager quelque chose de fondamental
instantanément et très simplement
alors évidemment pour arriver à cette
facilité d'expression avec la musique ça
demande énormément de travail
c'est pas c'est pas facile parce que
d'abord il faut s'affranchir des
contraintes techniques de l'instrument
il faut que la technique de l'instrument
devienne un prolongement de son corps et
de sa pensée
il faut aussi être suffisamment à l'aise
avec le langage musical qui est donc
universel pour pouvoir exprimer de façon
très naturelle très libérée qui on est
les histoires qu'on a à raconter les
choses qu'on a à dire des choses qu'on a
envie de partager
et pour ça je me suis toujours dit que
la musique c'était la liberté
d'expression suprême parce que
absolument tout peut se transformer en
musique la joie la plus enfantine
même la violence la plus laide n'y a pas
de tabou en musique en fête l'humour la
tendresse et moi elle me permet souvent
de me libérer de certaines choses
certains sentiments des émotions des
choses que j'ai envie de purger dont
j'ai envie presque de me débarrasser
je peux les mettre dans une petite boîte
et cette boîte c'est la musique et je
sais que ça va résonner chez les autres
humains parce qu'on est absolument tous
pareils je sais que ils vont comprendre
qu'ils vont recevoir que je vais être
compris et donc je ne suis plus seul
mais la musique quand elle est
personnelle elle demande de se
débarrasser de toute pudeur c'est c'est
un outil qui permet une impudeur total
dit rien c'est un outil qui demande une
impudeur total en fait la musique doit
être absolument sincère envers et contre
tout alors bon aujourd'hui 21 mais moi
je suis seul devant vous je suis venu en
solo j'ai découvert pendant quelques
années que la recherche de la limite de
la liberté passe souvent par la solitude
et que la solitude offre aussi beaucoup
de chemin vers la liberté et donc je
vais vous jouez pour terminer un morceau
que j'ai écrit il ya deux ans il
s'appelle letting go et pour moi il
parle de rupture de rupture amoureuse et
du moment où parfois on se rend compte
que on doit laisser l'autre partir et on
doit presque l'aider à aller s'épanouir
loin de nous c'est un peu comme ouvrir
la porte de la cage pour que l'oiseau
puisse s'envoler
merci beaucoup